oh hey good to see you thanks for having
us this is my
girlfriend we're so happy you could join
us and this is my wife so this is the
infamous
and has told me so much about you both
all good things I hope you could never
trust wait a minute and please please
don't call me makes me think my mother's
around some place
oh hey you know where where is little oh
she's at house for a slumber party oh oh
oh um and uh there was this is a couple
from New York that we wanted you guys to
meet uh this is and her
husband uh they're going to be in New
York for a few weeks so we were hoping
you could give them some tips sure oh
that'd be great so how do you know
and oh well and I went
to school of dramatic